a new order from DHS secretary Alejandro
mayorcas is warning border patrol agents
not to misgender illegal immigrants Yes
you heard that right so as we watch
massive crowds of migrants cross our
Southern border under President Biden's
watch nearly two and a half million now
it appears the White House is
prioritizing pronouns over actually
fixing the Border crisis or maybe even
just addressing it new DHS orders
obtained by the Heritage Foundation
instruct agents to quote ask in
individuals about their preferred
pronouns they suggest asking quote I
would like to be respectful what name
and pronoun would you like me to use
addressing you or ask can you please
confirm your pronouns or gender identity
the memo also tells agents not to use
pronouns like he and she and Mis and
ma'am until they are sure of how that
person would like to be
addressed Congressman I can't I can't
tell if I'm on an episode of South Park
or in a Far Side Car cartoon or an alien
joke because it is preposterous to think
that our border agents would be
instructed with these orders mind you
that's that's the primary order not
let's get you to safety not which Cartel
has a gun to your head right now not I'm
worried for my safety engaging the it is
nonsense but this is the continued
nonsense we get from this Administration
I'm I'm at a loss at this point and this
one this one right here I mean like said
maybe The Truman Show and I'm looking
for the back exit door cuz this when you
get to this point they're coming across
the border and record numbers the
administration is encouraging them to
come across the border this is the part
that I just don't honest to God don't
get you got a a secretary who is
blatantly bending the law to say
everything's better because we're
putting them through parole through the
actual you know in no you're not because
the law doesn't say that and by the way
95% of those who come on Asylum claims
will not be granted Asylum let's quit
the lie it's a lie my orcus you're so
bad at your job you make your boss
actually look good okay that's how bad
my orcus is at this but the m concern is
going back something you said Emily I've
been to the border to see our agents I
am tired of our border patrol agents
being made to daycare they''re been made
to to to keep people safe they're trying
to do their job as best they can as the
law says they should and they're being
mistreated over and over and over by
this Administration and mayorcas who's
at the head of their organization why
don't they actually say thank you and do
your job we'll give you the tools to do
your job when they're not able to do
their job we're putting our own border
agents in health concerns ways these
folks are coming across the border where
they're having to keep them in
unsanitary conditions because they don't
they're trying to get them out they're
doing their best and then their head of
their agency is saying don't misgender
them give me a break get actually to
real a and somebody figure this out he
ought to resign simply because he's
freaking incompetent Leslie to that
point can you say with a straight face
that any of these illegal immigrants
will actually care give the slightest
iota of care about their pronouns when
they are subjected to rapes and sexual
assaults and violence and extreme
poverty and the control that the these
cartels have and barely making it alive
because of these cartels and and they
think that being called by a proper
prent that's going to Sage everything
else who actually cares about this when
I first saw this I thought you guys
picked this because you know I was here
today no we would never shake it up
there we go uh look this one was when I
was like no I don't think it's a
priority I do think you do you are
should be respectful and there are some
people that would care who are trying to
escape persecution if they're
lgbtq uh members of you know that
community in some uh you know Central
and uh you know other Latin American
countries however you know let's give a
shout out to border patrol who just did
a fabulous job with a fent and all bus
that has stopped so many drugs from
coming in and has prevented and perhaps
saved many many lives in the process one
two we need to look at what immigration
is it's not just a mayorcas it's not
just a Biden it's not just Democrat it's
not just Republican because Democrats
and Republicans both in Congress are to
blame for the failure of this system we
have an Antiquated Asylum system we have
a multifaceted problem it takes a
multifaceted Solution that's just common
sens which I believe God gives all of us
equally and you know the bottom line is
Congress needs to act not just a
president but this memo doesn't help and
it doesn't help the perception because
immigration is a very important issue
for everyone I appreciate that answer um
and I think you know to those clean true
persecution then I would think the
safety of being alive still Trump's in
priority be whether they're called the
right pronoun they just they just want
to be safe you know and then to to the
point about the the 26 defendants now
for that fentel you know that wouldn't
have happened were it not for these
flooded borders under Biden's watch kayy
I wanted to draw your attention too now
now let's bring out the former president
his actions because actions matter and
endorsements arguably matter so this is
President Trump who went down to the
Border he's serving border agents a
Thanksgiving meal with gratitude and
acknowledgement two things we've yet to
see from our current president and
during that trip to Texas he scored an
arguably critical endorsement by
Governor Abbott what say you yeah you
know Leslie says it takes a multifaceted
solution absolutely it also takes a
competent leader we don't have a
competent leader we have President Biden
we did have a competent leader president
Trump who implemented a multifaceted
solution remain in Mexico build the wall
he threatened to put tariffs on Mexico
unless they mobilize their troops to
their northern border our Southern
border and it worked we are seeing now
record-breaking numbers on the southern
border that doesn't happen in a vacuum
it happens because in the words of oor
in Mexico he called Joe Biden the
migrant president he understands the
connection between policies and outcomes
and that's what we're seeing now um I
regret we don't have a competent leader
anymore but you know I used to hear
build the wall at Trump ralles but now a
majority 55% are shouting build the wall
together in the latest poll 55% support
building a wall because it worked takan
forgive this sort of overs simplistic
analogy but one time I was on it it was
on an international flight I was in Asia
the flight was totally insane it was
worst flight I didn't fly for two years
after it was so scary my point is all we
cared about was Landing safely I didn't
care whether peanuts were served or not
so I would think for those millions of
migrants flooding across our border
again they do not care how they are
addressed as long as they are alive and
more importantly I don't think border
agents care about the niceties put forth
by this Administration I think they care
about their safety and some type of
Purpose Driven career and their safety
that they are absolutely lacking under
this Administration uh I doubt that the
parents of the dead babies and the
children who drown trying to get across
the border really care about the
pronouns or the women who have been
repeatedly raped trying to get across
the border whove been repeatedly IGN
ignored by alandro mayorcas and this
Administration who laid the foundation
uh for all of this misery and suffering
uh I don't think people care who are
part of all of the communities who've
been financially and economically
crushed by this wide open border and
this is coast to coast this is a
catastrophe brought Upon This Nation by
this Administration and I kind of
challenge my orcas to maybe go to
Chicago where uh moment after moment
Time After Time the residents in Chicago
plagued by crime again brought upon them
by liberals in power but who have been
angry about PE the illegal migrants
taking over their Parks taking over
their
playgrounds let my orcus tell those
parents and those men and women that his
priority is
misgendering my illegal migrants
and pronouns and he I'd like to see what
those residents of Chicago have to say
to him about that you can't make it up
and just a reminder every time you see
orders your tax dollars went toward the
execution of even writing it and putting
it forth just a waste top to bottom hey
everyone I'm Emily compano catch me and
my co-hosts Harris vulner and Kaylee
mcki on outnumbered every weekday at
12:00 p.m. Eastern or sets your DVR also
don't forget to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page P for daily highlights